hey what's up guys I was in the middle
of writing a top 10 list for my favorite
Dragon Ball super foes when I realized
there are way way more than I initially
anticipated so many in fact that I
thought this was the perfect opportunity
to make a video where I review each
individual opponent Foe and villain in
10 words or less same rules as last time
I'll review each individual character
using 10 words or less while giving them
each a score out of 10. now there will
be negative scores too that doesn't mean
that they are worse than a 0 out of ten
it just measures its ironic enjoyment
because sometimes a hilariously bad
character is better than a boring one I
will be taking into account all
character purposes as well as their
impact on the overall product now with
all of that out of the way let's review
each individual antagonist in Dragon
Ball super in 10 words or less Hey look
it's an enemy I guess kinda you toei
please burn the peel off gang love tnm
interesting villain idea great design
and tons of new lore hey look guys the Z
Warriors can help now really cool design
but remove him and nothing really
changes easily the most tragic character
in this entire Arc hey you
what a neat little character who
facilitates a great twist the closest
Dragon Ball will ever get to an Oscar
I've got it what if beerus was fat
botamo more like board Tomo
genuinely took me by surprise and had
pretty compelling episodes
ah
characters is ready I've got it cover
chameleon he's fine I guess interesting
design with even more interesting
moveset half shark half man fighting
evil that's the plant Street Sharks
turns out Joliet is actually a really
cool character who knew still a better
anime than motamo at its literal sludge
maybe the most compelling character
revealed in the whole series
so close to being Grace but way too
cliche additional sympathetic moments
would have astronomically improved zamas
sorely needed fun lighthearted
antagonist after chaotic frustrating Arc
conclusion Hawkeye MJ stop trying to
make Barry Khan happen I bet you forgot
about this guy so did I strangely
nostalgic feel to this encounter very
Dragon Ball and just like that the
robber did more than botamo Basel
lavender and Bergamo these were the
ingredients chosen to create the perfect
asses to kick Justice
behind the Raditz of this group thanks
now we know and knowing is half the
battle a female super saiyan and it only
took 26 years Kale's power is maximumist
very satisfying ass kicking and they
facilitated 17's reveal win so this is
where Metroid came from weird frog
creature dressed in 18th century GARP
yeah okay could have been a fun
character 30 years ago first time roshi
fought Goku since early Dragon Ball
somehow I actually like this character
more than Sailor Moon anyone else think
about a mouse drinking tequila no okay
stop being such a [ __ ] oh my god dude
I'm inexplicably evil in the most
obvious way serviceable cannon fodder
for Frieza to go berserk on ladies
gentlemen I give you Shonen anime's
biggest problem personified the purest
example of a Dragon Ball character
terrifying cuteness oh what's that you
thought I forgot other characters in the
tournament of power well
instead of mercury Sailor Venus this guy
lasts longer than Hitler that's sink in
Father ooh Goku got a fight with a yard
rat so cool look I'm helping oops I gave
you the front Cape he's very shy
probably the most uninspired design in
the whole tournament tears toy on the
[ __ ] sort of not really fodder
facilitated some interesting scenes but
still fun Universe 3's most successful
fighter eliminates no one gets
eliminated spotter oh yeah I think I
remember seeing him kinda oh and he hung
out with him I think with a name like
that he should have looked more Italian
look a distraction fodder oh look more
fodder man this universe is screwed
really cool intimidating design
embarrassingly and easily eliminated
nothing special and a boring design this
counts a different character right right
Duck Dodgers and the 24th and a half
century eliminated worst elimination
ever I never knew the Deep Sea King had
a sister alright Sosha fooled me with
the whole playing dead thing I've been a
pretty crappy fighter man you
really cool design with a fun idea
classic yet fresh go home toe you're
drunk you may have lost but he's a
winner to me I didn't even know I wanted
this but yay basically Piccolo without
any of the cool personality they have
like three ways of drawing namekians in
Dragon Ball facilitated a great moment
with Frieza father you could yeah we do
face
full design still
still eh father who even is this guy
Fusion of Tian Krillin Hercule and boo
you're welcome terrible elimination but
she's so darsh dang cute what is this
was this guy even in the show okay now
you're making these up when was he there
at least we know where the great
crablante came from Vegeta what does the
scouter say about his power level
Universe 10 fashion rule always match
belt with skin you know you're terrible
when you're eliminated by a yard rat
probably the only Saving Grace from
Universe 10's roster flying fodder I is
individual I am also an individual I've
got no strings to hold me down
eliminated hey I'm just above green guy
like why toy why would you give this
thing life
prepare for trouble and that's everyone
up until the recording of this video now
to save you guys the trouble of digging
through my video for the scores here are
my top five favorite antagonists in
Dragon Ball super top 5 number 5 Zeno
this little football-headed bug-eyed
shortstock is the ultimate in all the
universe the very first instance we see
him both Champa and beerus turned to
putty heck even battles and we show
concern when Goku strolls on up to him
they don't once destroyed six out of the
existing 18 universes once with only 12
remaining Zeno has created a tournament
of power in which the losing universes
get destroyed as it stands no one in the
entire Dragon Ball series has taken more
lives number four hit once we initially
get over the hump of the movie arcs we
were greeted with an inter-universal
tournament between Universe 6 and
universe 7. the former of which was
captained by the character hit this
purple fighter of few words has some of
the strangest abilities in this series
and since his unveiling has facilitated
some of the most unique and fun battles
in the series truly a character you
don't want to waste your time skipping
number three Goku black literally
everything this character did I enjoyed
from his thrilling and suspenseful
unveiling to his epic and fierce battles
with Vegeta Trunks and Goku this
character took a concept long wish for
amongst the fan base and turned it into
something truly memorable he's merciless
he's powerful he wants to wipe out every
last human he's black number two beerus
what can I say about this character that
hasn't already been said beerus is the
reason why Dragon Ball super exists and
is playing out the way it currently is
he's introduced the concept of gods
multiple universes God energy and the
overarching hierarchy that the universe
is based on on top of that he comes
packed with a fantastic design and
endearing snarky personality and
surprisingly has a wonderfully
interesting relationship with Son Goku
he falls short of nabbing the number one
spot but just by a hair number one
golden Frieza if you were to ask me what
I thought of Frieza after the movie in
2015 I would have given you a lukewarm
response however watsuper has done with
the character Frieza has been nothing
short of fantastic during the
resurrection F Arc we got to see Frieza
in full swing with the murdering of his
crew and his brutal training with taguma
however it wasn't until the universe
survival Arc that the Frieza character
reached New Heights everything from his
cunning underhanded tactics to his
bloodthirsty Psychopathic Rampages to
his patient plan to overthrow the Gods
Frieza is one of the few characters that
in my mind has stood the test of time
and is just as relevant now as he was
one quarter century ago
but who really wants to know who the
best are it's definitely more fun and
controversial to rag on characters and
creative choices secondary and tertiary
characters from the tournament of Power
are exempt as they were never intended
to be anything significant in the first
place to qualify you must have at least
one episode as the focus and so here are
my bottom five antagonists bottom five
number five watagashi effectively this
is a way way worse version than the
parasite from parasite Maxim it just
makes people these hulking brutes with
furry shoulders that are almost as
confusing as JoJo's hat slash hair thing
he has going on seriously what is up
with that thing watagashi's only purpose
is to give a bit of shine to a character
everyone had pretty much given up on at
this point number four urine with a [ __ ]
motivation and equally fitting name
urine acts as a character for one
episode and along with a shoehorn
backstory kind of almost not really puts
up a fight with 10 shinhan and Goku the
purpose of this episode is to
reintroduce us back to Tien and that's
pretty much it she is very forgettable
number three she saw me as a character
who was in multiple episodes and had an
imposing design I was expecting much
much more from this big red brute he
effectively shows up punches a bit gives
Gohan a tight hug gets overpowered by
Gohan and shocked by Frieza that's it
and I'm not cheaping out on you here
that's literally everything he
contributes number two jiren I am going
to get crucified for having this guy on
my list but before you raise your
pitchforks hear me out everything that
is wrong with Dragon Ball can be found
in this character inexplicably strong
check little to no dialogue check no
personality check no backstory check
came out of effectively nowhere just so
that Goku wouldn't be the most powerful
one in the tournament check jiren
facilitates one thing competition for
Goku and I know that this is a common
problem throughout Dragon Ball it's even
an issue in Z that's true but you know
what cell Majin Buu beerus hit Goku
black and zamasu all had in common
interesting personalities one of the
most polarizing characters in the entire
series and one that I also hate Broly
has a lot in common with jiren he's just
this big brute that is powerful because
[ __ ] you if it later comes to light that
jiren actually has a personality then
great but as of right now everything
from his design motivation and
personality is either non-existent lazy
or uninspired if he wasn't the main
focus of this entire Arc I'd let him off
but he is number one botamo he's [ __ ]
boring always poorly animated boring on
original Bland design boring does
nothing for the main characters is
completely void of personality and is so
[ __ ] boring forget Dragon Ball super
this guy could be the most boring
opponent in all of Dragon Ball if you
guys would like to see more content like
this feel free to subscribe down below I
try to upload at least once a week and I
take suggestions from the comments also
don't forget to leave a like if you
enjoyed the video and I'll see you guys
next week thank you so much for watching